this video contains information from
Frank Herbert's original dune saga and
also the dune encyclopedia the race
knows its own mortality and fears
stagnation of its heredity it's in the
bloodstream the urge to mingle genetic
strains without plan the Imperium the
chome company all the Great Houses they
are but bits of flotsam in the path of
the flood Frank Herbert dune in the dune
saga chome is the largest single source
of wealth in the universe the combine o
net Oh bear Advent sir mercantile x'
abbreviated as shown controls all
economic affairs across the universe
shown like everyone else relies upon the
spacing yield for faster than light
travel chum touched nearly every product
moved by the guild from technology to
spice melange many of the great and
minor houses depended on the profits of
Chone and an enormous portion of those
profits depended on the most valued
commodity in the universe the spice
melange which extended life heightened
awareness and was necessary to space
travel at the start of dune the
harkonnens have held Arrakis in quasi
fief under a chome company contract to
mine melange the flag of chome is yellow
with the half red and half black circle
at its centre directorship cinchona are
the key to wealth in the universe each
noble house took what it could shown
directorships are the real evidence of
political power in the universe
the spacing guild and the many Jesuit
sisterhood are silent partners within
Chun
the padishah Emperor and the landsraad
controlled the management of the
corporation and the Board of Directors
the landsraad represents the Great
Houses of the Imperium chome is similar
in structure to that of any corporation
it is made up of shareholders and major
shareholders are given directorships
that lead to the board of directors all
shareholders in chome however are
members of noble houses though all
directorships are held by the great
houses the emperor has the power to
bestow and revoke directorships as he
pleases after the rise of the god
emperor later the second the influence
that chom possessed was drastically
reduced but this was the case with all
organizations during the reign of the
worm god emperor according to the Dune
encyclopedia in the days before the
machines were violently expunged from
the Imperium in the event called the but
Larian jihad there was no singular
entity such as chome which possessed a
ruling or economic power throughout the
inhabited planets planetary trade in
those days was barbarous and played with
piracy then after the machine crusade
ended trade went dark in this time
before the discovery of spice and the
creation of the guild machines had been
used to traverse the universe without
them space travel became not only far
more expensive but dangerous many ships
were lost traveling through hyperspace
without the guide of a machine
300 years after the but Larry in jihad
the emperor saw dear the first became
aware of the spacing guild he quickly
realized that the only way to deal with
the guild was on a basis of mutual
advantage
he created Joan in the year 10 BG the
Emperor summoned the representatives of
the guild the landsraad and the imperial
house they made agreements and based on
what they agreed each member had much to
lose or gain from the existence of the
guild which provided fast and easy space
travel through a genius use of
purposeful misdirection the guild was
able to keep their dependence on the
spice transfer their navigational
abilities a secret by leaking
information about the geriatric
properties of the spice melange the
spice slowed aging they ensured their Co
participants would not look more deeply
into the other properties of the spice
melange the geriatric qualities of
melange intensified the feelings of the
landsraad towards the guild and the
return of galactic trade they knew that
they themselves were vulnerable to the
effects of trade and this added to the
reasons they wish to control the guilt
eventually both the guild and the
landsraad realised that their desires
aligned both groups one at the return of
trade but only in a manner that would
allow each organization to survive the
spacing guild
unlike the noble houses of the landsraad
cared not for the economic benefits of
trade the guild was solely concerned
with the socio-political effects of
cultural interaction between worlds for
many years neither group was able to
accomplish their goals the most powerful
Great Houses had ambitions of becoming
the Imperial house they saw the guild as
an opportunity to rule the Imperium by
seizing control of this new form of
trade the guild however would not deal
with them eventually after years the
Emperor Saudi recalled the delegates
into full session and presented the
plans for the formation of Chun
the plan was to create a corporation
which would have a monopoly on
interstellar an intersystem trade
membership in Choma was limited to the
feudal governments who ruled at least
one planet the emperor was assigned 20%
of the shares far less than the amount
he could rightfully take and granting
the imperial house only one-fifth of
Joan's shares the invar replaced the
imperial house in a position where it
would be necessary for it to depend on
many other feudal powers if it were to
successfully control the corporation
over the next five centuries the Empire
experienced a period of rapid growth
expanded by conquest eventually the
Empire controlled all the habitable
planets available to the current
navigational abilities of the gilt the
new trade system was easily supported
after the formation of Choma the steady
expansion of the Empire not only
replaced the losses but added to the
available resources in this time the
Emperor's power had grown significantly
the imperial house controls 25% of chome
shares including the voters he
controlled the number was closer to 35%
though this was not an outright majority
it still created unrest among the Great
Houses who noticed the trend the Emperor
could nearly always persuade at least
15% or more partners the result being
that in almost all instances the
partners affirmed the position of house
Kirino still in those days the emperor
and his supporters never controlled more
than 60% of the vote and the Emperor
himself never more than 40 the economic
balance was such that the century to
century change was never more than 10%
which was easily sustainable some minor
houses were indeed able to raise himself
to the status of Great Houses it wasn't
until the rise of House Atreides that
this all changed
when Paul Atreides defeated house Kirino
with his free man army the only
immediate effect on Chone was the
transfer of 38% of the Directorate votes
from house Kirino to House Atreides this
was the total of house Kirino shares at
the time many revolted against House
Atreides each house that defied House
Atreides was defeated and their shares
were taken over by the time all the
revolting houses lay defeated House
Atreides owned 51% of the chome company
shares making it the first time in
history that the imperial house had
outright control of Chung the priesthood
of MU Adeeb controlled 5% of the shares
in addition all of this inspired a large
amount of hate for House Atreides not
only had the people of the Imperium lost
much of their wealth they were exposed
to an increasingly despotic rule Joe
managed to survive before and after the
death of the god Emperor during the time
of the scattering and during the return
of the honored ma trace how's it going
guys if you like this video please leave
a like and also subscribe if you want to
see more also consider supporting this
channel on patreon if you pledge $5 or
more you get this cool bookmark with all
these quotes on it and if you pledge any
amount you get access to all the content
that goes up there that's not on YouTube
thanks for watching guys
[Music]
you